[Music]
foreign you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with Rachel cunliff
senior associate editor at the new
Statesman and the political editor of
The Spectator Katie balls with us from
now until just before midnight welcome
to both of you so to the front pages
then let's start with the metro and the
first plane load of British people
evacuated from Sudan Landing in Cyprus
hours after they were told to dash
unescorted through its embattled capital
to an airstrip the Metro reports while
the eye says British troops are ready to
use Force as evacuation efforts continue
to get UK citizens out of Sudan
the telegraph has the headline Harry
Court claims leave coronation peace
hopes in tatters the guardian is also
reporting on that story with claims that
the lake Queen threatened Rupert
Murdoch's media firm with legal action
over phone hacking
the financial times is on the U.S
President Joe Biden's announcement that
he will seek a second term in the White
House well the Daily Mirror says
desperate families received
three million emergency food Parcels
last year with one million of them for
children
the chief Economist at the bank of
England has said British people must
accept they are worse off and stop
asking for more pay that is the lead for
the Daily Mail
well a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
so let's head straight to Our Guest then
Rachel can live from the new Statesman
and Katie balls from The Spectator
welcome to both of you
um Katie why don't you start with the
guardian then and the very latest
pictures of some of those Britain's
scrambling to get out of Sudan
unescorted as we said there does it
appear though that the the government
via the ministry of Defense are getting
their act together
yeah
I think there's definitely a sign of I
think Improvement might be too bold but
if you think about the music yesterday
speaking to senior Tories
um figures um involved there was a
pacifism that perhaps the UK government
had missed the boat when it came to
offering a way out for um UK citizens
and there was definitely some unrest out
of the fact that diplomats had managed
to evacuate first so I think the fact
that one flight is gone we're told more
later today
um does at least suggest that there is a
plan of motion and it's obviously a very
complicated situation geographically and
also politically but just in terms of
the how you do this and but it
definitely feels a little bit more I
think as though there is a path
um as to where the mistakes have been
made and how much kslb that I think that
remains to be seen well certainly the
ministry of Defense has released the
first pictures then of the people
getting off that flight in Cyprus
pointing out that further flights will
follow throughout tonight and tomorrow's
work continues to move UK Nationals to
safety as you can see some of the people
offloading that plane via a bus there
from the airport perimeter standing by
to take them much really for them no
doubt the problem seems to be that this
Airfield north of the capital is
currently being run by the Germans
Rachel and Ben Wallace the defense
secretary is suggesting that the UK will
take it over effectively tomorrow which
means they can start getting more people
out because the window of opportunity is
this ceasefire isn't it
yes there's a 72-hour ceasefire and the
effort obviously to get as many people
out as possible the first Brits on that
plane as we have seen uh but there are
thousands more left 2 000 people applied
for evacuation uh and the question is
really how many flights are going to be
able to take off in that time period
there's also talk of trying to do a sea
evacuation moving people to the port and
getting them out that way and the line
from the government is very much that
they are doing this at the first
available safe opportunity and that when
it comes to sort of a mass evacuation
like this you obviously need to plan it
carefully and it made sense to get
diplomatic Personnel out first because
they were directly being targeted but
just looking at the situation what other
countries have been doing it does look
as if perhaps the planning stage of
Britain's evacuation hadn't been done
the preparation she hadn't been done as
much as you might hope and there are
also questions about the conflict itself
and how much preparation how much that
was foreseen by British diplomats and by
the by the foreign office here because
we've been talking about this over the
last couple of days like it came out of
nowhere it didn't come out of nowhere
tensions have been wisely for some time
and you would hope that there are people
in in our diplomatic service in in the
foreign office who are keeping an eye in
the military even on exactly these kinds
of situations and have plans in place
for when they need to act very quickly
so I think even when this evacuation is
over there'll be some very challenging
very tough questions for the foreign
office to answer yes we saw the times
there make your own way to get that
airlift the Metro run for your lives is
there is their headline now Ben Wallace
was quite defensive about this was he
not saying there's not a one-size-fits
all we can't really offer advice some
parts of Khartoum are fighting some are
not some people be able to access it
easily others will not
um suggesting that's the reason they've
had to be careful and circumspect and
what they're saying and the reason they
had to get the diplomats out so quickly
is that's where the fighting is the two
sides had their headquarters nearby and
there was a direct threat from that I
mean is that fair enough do you think
that there's you know the people are so
disparate and they can't be specific
about whether it's safe for you to leave
right now Katie
is clearly a very complicated situation
I think on the diplomats is clearly um
and you've seen that today a bad looking
way to get diplomats out before
um UK Nationals who are stuck there
particularly when they're saying they
can't go on phone lines and they're
being told they don't have food and
where they're staying and they're very
frightened but there was also I think
quite a plausible case being made there
was more of a direct threat on the
diplomats partly for the reasons you
just mentioned and and therefore I think
there's lots of comparisons at the
moment between will this be a repeat of
Afghanistan which is clearly a very
chaotic
evacuation and I I think that it's too
soon to say for sure but you can see the
government trying to learn for some of
the mistakes of the past so for example
you had James cleverley the foreign
secretary last week cut his trip short
to get back I think in anticipation the
situation could get worse now that might
not be something which has a a huge
impact from the people who are stuck
there but of course it is quite
different to Dominic Robb during
Afghanistan where we had the foreign
actually the time on a holiday and a big
debate about where the sea was open or
not so so I think you can see an attempt
at least to learn the lessons but with
these things it's really hard because
what the government can say in public
isn't necessarily what's going on behind
the scenes because it's just such a
complicated situation yes chaotic like
Afghanistan
um but but in a sense Afghanistan was a
bit easier was it not
um we had 20 days of notice to get
people out there a military footprint
already established the airport was
controlled by by the US and the UK in
Parts too this there's nothing like that
is there in Sudan uh Rachel and and
looking at the eye they're talking about
the uh the terms of service if you like
for the military UK troops are ready to
use force in this airlift they will be
able to engage militia forces if the
operation comes under attack that's what
the paper's saying
yeah it's all a lot more chaotic than
Afghanistan the the Taliban gave notice
and they also offered a window where
they basically said here's your deadline
get your people out and countries had to
move very fast towards that deadline and
clearly a lot of mistakes were made
particularly when it comes to Afghan
Nationals who were assisting our forces
and our embassies that who we weren't
able to to get out but at least there
was a a time frame this is not a
government kind of kicking the UK forces
out this is a civil conflict it's a lot
more uncertain and uh the the argument
from from the defense Ministry has been
that it it kind of wasn't necessarily
safe to give people advice and tell them
where to go while the fighting was was
going on which is why this this
ceasefire is crucial but that line there
in the eye about uh the Army being able
to engage private militias just sort of
shows how uncertain and how chaotic it
it is
um as as Katie said it's a highly
complex situation and there's but
probably more things that we don't know
at the moment than that we do the
criticism of the UK government I think
is coming simply by looking at the
actions of other governments to get
their people out and the sense possibly
unfair but the sense that they have done
more preparation and more planning for
this scenario than we have yes well
certainly the the promises of more
flights tonight so we'll keep an eye on
the situation from akriteria and Cyprus
to this Airfield the what is Airfield
north of Khartoum in the meantime let's
move on to Joe Biden let's get the job
finished
um fascinating this isn't it or sets up
the prospect of a fascinating contest
next year Katie
um but the age issue has certainly been
raised
yes um I think there are some who
question uh Joe Biden's um
articulousness in his current term level
in a second
um obviously very much an aging
politician um older than any of the
current political leaders here in the UK
um and I think it's an interesting one
in the sense is it best for the
Democrats that they stay with Joe Biden
and there's so much uncertainty about
the Republican candidate it does feel as
though there is a chance we're heading
to a repeat situation of a Joe Biden
Donald Trump election and one which I
think the Democrats probably would
feel better in a way Joe Biden going
against Donald Trump than you know
another candidate
um but you do wonder if um you are going
to have some democratic challenges
um come out because um they're having
concerns that uh the way things have
been going for a while now
yes and he urged voters to help him
thwart the extremists um it's the fight
for democracy against those who backed
the capital riots that's the the framing
of this so far Rachel
yes you could see images there as he's
announcing uh are against the backdrop
you've got images of the January Capital
Riot and uh that that has been a
a very effective messaging strategy for
the Democrats even uh people who U.S
citizens who would normally vote
Republican who don't like the Democrats
that incident seeing the the interaction
and particularly seeing the response
from Donald Trump and indeed from the
Republican party in in the wake of that
not wanting to see it as a as a coup and
to take it as seriously as you might
hope that any party would in a
democratic country that has really
harmed the Republicans among kind of
Centrist moderate voters or even those
who are sort of Leaning Republicans so
it's not surprising that Joe Biden is
capitalizing on that it's also not
surprising that he wants another go at
it given that
um you know that let's finish the job
that's kind of a classic uh election
slogan for a president seeking a a
second term but the age thing you know
that that is notable he's uh currently
80 he'll be 82 at the time of of the
election Trump obviously is uh 76.
um this is the idea of a rerun now with
these two two men who uh are at that
stage of their life there are questions
being asked about are they the best
candidates are they the freshest
candidate are they the candidates with
the most energy uh and is is a rerun of
that particular Grudge Match really the
best thing for American politics right
now but it is looking increasingly
likely that it will be Trump who gets
the nomination in case unless something
you know one of the court cases against
him radically derails that and I imagine
team Biden are thinking well it worked
once let's try it again yeah it's
absolutely fascinating isn't it um yep
sets up quite a contest certainly let's
take a look at the Daily Telegraph now
Katie Harry Court claims leave
coronation peace hopes and tatters
multiple allegations coming out of
Prince Harry's legal team one that his
brother settled for a big sum to the
late Queen backed the Duke of sussex's
bid for an apology but Charles blocked
it so take it away
yeah it's um
many developments uh just in time for
the coronation and I think there are
initially hopes that um the coronation
and King Charles would be a moment the
family could come back together after
obviously a very difficult period
um it from all the briefings it feels as
though uh Prince William is not in a
place to uh forgive his brother over his
memoir
um but but could have this been the
moment I think it it seems from the
telegraph piece and also more generally
um that develops in this court case um
are just going to add to the amino you
know the tensions that already exist
um and now ultimately when it comes to
this the suggestion is that Prince
William accepted assessment uh when it
came to
um obviously this Murdock payment and
this comes as uh Prince Harry who we
know has won to take on the UK press he
has a history of doing it is charting
his own course
um and the paper also says that um they
do not believe that Prince William knew
about what Prince Harry is going to say
ahead of it being made public and and
therefore could further straighten the
relationship so I think you have two
stories here one age of a family which
is pretty broken and there's a little
sign of reconciliation even ahead of
such a you know big event for both
family in the country and then the
second is of course about the press and
the different approaches from the royal
family to that